bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat je vous propose tout de
suite de faire une petite parenthèse
dans cette journée spéciale consacrée
aux 50 ans du traité de l'élysée avec la
diffusion d'un colloque qui s'est tenu
le 17 janvier au sénat à l'initiative de
la délégation sénatoriale à l'outre-mer
mais aussi du ministère des affaires
étrangères sur la place de la france
dans le pacifique
il faut dire que depuis de nombreuses
années les atouts que représentent les
collectivités françaises dans le
pacifique ont suscité de nombreuses
attentes vis-à-vis de la france
alors la france dans le pacifique quelle
vision pour le 21e siècle
éléments de réponse avec ce colloque le
ciel premier ministre cheikh michel
rocard messieurs les ambassadeurs
mes chers collègues mon cher collègue
député lesterlin secrétaire délégation
d'outre-mer à l'assemblée nationale mes
chers amis avant de céder la parole
modérateur de cette première table ronde
madame nathalie mort goodrich auteur
d'une thèse remarqué sur la france dans
le pacifique sud
il me revient l'honneur le plaisir
d'introduire le thème de cette matinée
consacrée aux grands enjeux politiques
et stratégiques de la présence française
dans le pacifique
chacun connaît cette phrase de richelieu
les larmes de nos souverains ont le goût
salé de la mer qu'ils l'ont ignoré le
sens de ce colloque est bien évidemment
de nous inviter à ne pas ignorer la toux
considérable que constituent nos
territoires d'outre-mer du pacifique
nous ne devons pas oublier qu'avec un
territoire maritime de 7 millions de
kilomètres carrés et un demi million
d'habitants ces territoires font de la
france un état du pacifique à part
entière dans le cadre de la préparation
du livre blanc sur la défense nationale
avec mon collègue andré trillard la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense
et des forces armées du sénat nous a
chargé d'un rapport sur la montée en
puissance des enjeux maritimes dans le
monde notre rapport intitulé la maritime
isation deux points la france face à une
nouvelle géopolitique des océans
souligner l'importance des intérêts de
la france dans le pacifique tant d'un
point de vue stratégique qu économiques
et politiques
en un mot la mare utilisation
c'est une question de flux et une
augmentation sans précédent du nombre de
porte conteneurs qui eric tous les jours
l'ensemble des économies mais c'est
aussi une question de ressources avec
l'épuisement des ressources terrestres
demain les réserves d'hydrocarbures et
de minéraux des sous sols marins et le
potentiel en énergies renouvelables des
océans seront vitaux pour les économies
les entreprises de prospection et même
d'exploitation se multiplient les océans
devienne un objet de convoitise faisant
de la maîtrise des mers un élément
essentiel de la compétition
internationale demain une partie de la
croissance mondiale viendra de la mer ce
basculement de la terre vers la mer
entraîne des conséquences stratégiques
majeurs que nous avons détaillé région
par région dans le rapport et en
particulier dans le pacifique
l'enjeu pour nos territoires du
pacifique était évidemment de savoir
comment protéger leurs ressources
je pense ressources halieutiques et
minérales mais surtout comment les
valoriser et mieux insérer ses économies
dans une zone qui est devenu déjà le
centre de gravité de l'économie mondiale
ce sont là des défis considérables dont
vous parleront d'éminentes personnalités
successivement le directeur d'asie et
d'océanie du ministère des affaires
étrangères madame laurent monsieur
michel rocard qu'on ne présente pas
cette fois ci en qualité
de président du comité france
territoires du pacifique
messieurs mesdames les ambassadeurs
d'australie et de nouvelle zélande
cette insertion des territoires français
au sein de la zone pacifique passe
notamment par une montée en puissance de
la coopération militaire
nous observons avec satisfaction que
nous ta qui sous-tend 10 et les
irritants nucléaire ayant disparu nos
amis australiens et néo zélandais semble
mieux apprécier notre contribution à la
stabilité régionale au reste
nous avons tout à gagner au renforcement
du partenariat stratégique avec ses
grands pays pour renforcer la
complémentarité de nos moyens nous avons
l'évidence des intérêts communs en
matière de surveillance des pêches de
maintien de la paix de lutte contre les
trafics et activités illicites et
d'organisation des secours lors des
catastrophes naturelles la france
riveraine souveraine est légitime dans
le pacifique doit y être audacieuse et
ambitieuse malgré les difficultés
financières du moment
il nous faut en effet garder à l'esprit
les temps long et les perspectives d'une
planète où le pacific sera au 21ème
siècle pôle majeur de croissance
face au déploiement des forces armées
américaines dans la région
mais surtout à la montée en puissance et
en présence de la marine chinoise
la france doit mobiliser les moyens de
ses ambitions dans la région devons
notamment y défendent le respect du
droit maritime international et au
premier chef la liberté de navigation
dans les eaux internationales et se pose
naturellement la question
par quels moyens maritimes militaire
pouvons nous répondre à ces enjeux
stratégiques
ce sera à thèmes notamment abordé par le
secrétaire général de la mer monsieur
aymeric et l'amiral vichot thème tout à
fait essentiel car ces territoires
d'outre-mer avait été quelque peu
oubliée par le livre blanc de 2008
marine française devra
faire face à partir de 2015 un défi là
aussi considérable de renouvellement de
ses moyens d'intervention de
surveillance et de sûreté maritime dans
ces régions voilà autant de thèmes qui
devraient utilement nourrir cette
matinée et je voudrais ici remercier
encore une fois mon collègue et ami
serge larcher président de la délégation
sénatoriale à l'outre-mer d'avoir
organisé ce colloque dont je ne doute
pas qu'il sera fécond bien là on nous
allons lancer cette première table ronde
qui va a porté essentiellement sur les
grands enjeux politiques et stratégiques
de la présence française dans le
pacifique et qui englobera deux
thématiques essentielles à savoir
premièrement la politique française du
pacifique et ensuite les moyens
militaires et maritimes qui symbolise ou
qui caractérise les la présence pense
être une façon de près de caractériser
la présence française dans le pacifique
sud donc nous allons commencer par cette
première thématique
je rappellerai simplement à nos
interlocuteurs que nous sommes supposés
vous êtes supposés intervenir pendant à
peu près cinq minutes chacun pour
qu'ensuite nous puissions débattre
discuter de ces deux grandes thématiques
donc je me permets tout d'abord
d'introduire monsieur michel rocard oui
vous que je ne présente pas non plus et
vous
madame la directrice mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames et
messieurs j'ai pensé par demander pardon
d'être un mauvais call au camp devant
parce que je suis arrivé en retard mais
j'habite à 45 minutes de paris
j'avais deux heures et demie de route
s'il fallait être là à 9 heures merci de
me le pardonner et vous avez encore
parce que j'ai pas écrit voit
l'intervention j'ai pas le temps
si on enregistre vous fait ce que vous
voudrez et troisième parce que je vais
probablement dépasser votre talent veut
faire parler moi du pacifique sud
c'est pour des riches ces dépassements
de ma vie et tout le monde le sait donc
vous pardonnerai j'espère mais je vais
commencer par red rigolarde et j'y perd
une minute
hier soir il m'a fallu patienter pour
une conversation entre bafa b2c fille
le téléphone tardé à s'engouffrer je
prends un vieux livre dans la
bibliothèque
je l'avais lu quand une sortie 1993
histoire du nouveau monde et au passage
hier soir ça se passe je découvre ce
paragraphe qui s'appelle la françafrique
la française antarctique et il me faut
saisir cette occasion de vous rappeler
ici que la première apparition dans la
littérature française de l'expression la
france en arctique et dans des poèmes de
jean dell et de françois villon au tout
début du xvème siècle
alors c'est en plus une escroquerie
historique puisque la bizarrerie qui est
à l'origine de tout ça et l'étrangeté
des rapports fraternels et curieux que
d'effets très tôt dès français en haut
avec les populations indiennes de ce
brésil qu'on venait de découvrir lots
port de dieppe le havre et honfleur
échanger des produits des services
on l'avait conçu un village de huttes
aux bords de seine
pas très loin de du havre pour donner
l'idée de ces populations dites de
l'antarctique à l'époque qui était en
fête brésilienne
c'est un drôle de souvenir mais ça
mérite de se voir rappeler tout de même
ensuite vient notre grande période de
découverte et de colonisation
il faut dire que la france sur 100 la
nbm notre culmination est complètement
anarchique sans intention régulatrice de
puissance publique sans plan coordonné
et elle est faite au hasard de nos
grands capitaines un peu n'importe
comment
ce qu'on va voir avec cette nouvelle
calédonie qui nous tombent dans les bras
sur une belle opération militaire j'ai
pas le temps mais dont on a pas très
longtemps pas su quoi faire et qui a
donc commencé par être un pénitencier
avant d'être vouée aux intérêts privés
autour du nickel et tout est sur des
stars comme elle pouvait dans une assez
grande indifférence le métropolis yale
il faut bien le dire j'arrête
et il vous faut bien vous dire que vos
envois je suis arrivé à la découverte de
tout ça
les hasards de la vie font encore 1981
sans être jamais sorti de mon pays
puisque mes attributions était hexagonal
je suis inspecteur des finances
mais voilà leur ministre du plan le plan
c pour tout le monde ça n'intéresse
personne puisque j'appartenais un
gouvernement très résolus à des coutures
rien et concis de planification et à se
moquer éperdument
mais ça m'a donné l'occasion de temps de
réfléchir et si là que j'ai fait la
découverte affreuse que la totalité des
possessions présence française outre-mer
pacifique haussez indiens caraïbes était
menacée gravement dans leur avenir
économique
la panique me prend je gardais souvent
là tout premier combat
nous relations avec ses possessions
d'outre-mer comme avec tout vos anciens
au truc
l'ancien que des issas valais avec
chacun des états d'afrique étaient sous
le signe de l'exclusive aucun au
territoire tous gouvernés par des
préfets et aux ordres de nos ministères
centraux avaient interdiction
d'entretenir des relations avec les
territoires voisins
non seulement commerce interdit
l'exploration attia tu mets en plus
interdiction faite s'il vous plaît
le haut-commissaire où allons-nous
préfet de rencontrer les ambassadeurs de
france dans les pays voisins
quelquefois nous assez nerveux furent du
tourisme dans le pays
jamais une relation permise ma première
victoire et d'avoir dès 1981 82 obtenu
qu'il soit mis fin à l'exclusivité suit
donc le créateur de ces secrétariat
permanent un pour le caraïbes 1 pour
l'océan indien un pour le pacifique qui
réunissait tous nos préfets et aux
commissaires présents dans ces régions
il devrait avoir maintenant vocation il
rassembler les poisons de territoire
mais ça commence par les préfets avec
les ambassadeurs de france 2 les pays
voisins justement avec l'ordre de suivre
les affaires de noël des relations
commerciales et de commencer cette
politique corse donc qu'en 1981 qui
dépend du tout encore achevée et qui
consiste à créer un enracinement
économique de chacune de nos positions
nouveau revers dans son environnement
régional proche
c'est le premier acquis qu'il est déjà
majeure et je garde en tête que ça va
très mal et qu'il va falloir être
sérieux avec l'outre-mer et puis on
m'envoie mes visites de l'agriculture
j'étais né à courbevoie dans le vent
lieu urbaine
je fais partie de ceux qui ont du mal à
distinguer une vache d'un boeuf les huit
toute la profession agricole se moquait
il varie ville catastrophe quelques
heures il faut ouvrir les négociations
de l'uruguay round annonce ce sera la
première fois que l'agriculteur sera
jointe à l'industrie dans cette
politique d'ouverture des frontières et
j'ai découvre l'avenir d'une négociation
à 140 nations avec le but exclusif de
faire baisser les prix et le but at 8 if
suivi par les anglo saxons et avant de
casser la politique agricole commune qui
commençait
cette négociation allait s'engager sans
juge sans arbitre sans officiantes ific
commun établissant les chiffres chacun
mentait sur ces chiffres nationaux et
comme il y avait dix jugent dix arbitres
lee médiation ça ne pouvait finir qu'à
la force évidence il fallait des alliés
et comme dans la négociation entre les
consommateurs il allait on pouvait pas
éviter une sous négociations sur les
grands producteurs exportateurs menacé
cette affaire ils étaient 7 mai j'ai
sortir tout de suite de la hisse le
premier entre le brésil puisque les
huiles végétales ne sont pas dans la
négociation
donc il reste six états unis canada
australie nouvelle zélande argentine
communauté européenne
quels alliés bien sûr l'argentine le
premier mais seulement pour la viande de
boeuf s'est pas produit stratégique ça
ne suffit pas le cadre est on prêt sont
loin de dieu est trop près des états
unis on l'a souvent des comme le mexique
impossible à les y force les états unis
avec une religion simple il fallait
sortir de tout ça et les équilibres de
marché
toute idée d' organisation des marchés
toute idée de prospective à long terme
était exclu je lis va car du monde et je
découvre que deux pays que je
connaissais pas donc je n'avais jamais
entendu parler ou j'avais naturellement
jamais mis les pieds
la nouvelle zélande et l'australie sont
eux à ce moment là dirigés par des
sociaux-démocrates une famille souvent
maudite un peu moins depuis six mois en
france
l'anf aval complète qui avec
l'économique macroéconomie lointaine une
relation extrêmement long et elle est
toujours d'ailleurs pas très établies
vous le savez tous très bien mais je me
dis que des détenteurs du pouvoir dans
ces pays ne pouvait pas être des
disciples de milton friedman ne
pouvaient pas être des esclaves de la
philosophie de l'économie de marché mais
comment faire faut des alliés
comment les trouver on ne sait jamais
parlé nos cimetières militaires sont
plaints de tombes voisines beaucoup
d'australiens quelques démos zélandais
et pas mal de français c'est tout ce que
nous avons fait ensemble avec beaucoup
d'autres j'avais jamais dans l'histoire
sauf une seule fois à laquelle je vais
dire tout à l'heure il s'est fait quoi
que ce soit entre la france et
l'australie
comment faire connaissance d'autant que
nous faisons sauter des bombes dans le
pacifique
nous sommes enchantés l'australie avait
permis la crèche alors is et la création
du fort du pacifique que je mettrais dix
ans à connaître pour en recevoir les
félicitations sur ce que fait la france
dans le pacifique mais s'est dit soit
prêt pour le moment l'objectif du ford
s'était dehors la france le hasard joue
le hasard c'est qu'à une présidence
tournante en europe
la france devient présidente au premier
semestre 84 je deviens président du
conseil agricole deuxième hasard il faut
dans ce conseil agricole la renouveler
le très mauvais accord tactiquement il
exécrable triennal qui d'où l'ire
nouvelle zélande et que la grande
bretagne avait exigé ou vendre sa propre
adhésion et tout le monde à voir les
irlandais second les français
presqu'aussi rtu verse police se
débarrasser de mes zélande et la basse a
créé avec son droit de s'exporter du de
l'agneau est là tuez-le mans du beurre
et je devais président du conseil
agricole là dedans
j'ai dit aux éleveurs sont pas
stratégiques c'est pas mon problème mais
faut donner un petit signe va donner un
petit signe je vais abusé outrageusement
j'ai pas été poursuivi par aucun
tribunal lui par la cour européenne
j'ai abusé outrageusement de ma position
de plaisir un conseil d'école bénéficié
du fait que j'avais un secrétaires
d'état gentil pour diriger la délégation
française dans la défense de ses
intérêts contre tous les autres et je
pilote cette négociation pour avantager
outrageusement la nouvelle zélande avec
un millier todd plus daliot et emilio
tonnes de plus de beurre que son
excellent ambassadeur de l'époque vous
avez de grands prédécesseurs madhab
avait calculé
il était très expert qu'il avait des
chances de récupérer à la sortie
j'ai mon résultat la une des journaux
titrent nouvelle-zélande
la nouvelle-zélande se découvre un avis
qu'elle ne connaissait pas qu'est ce que
c'est que ce qui naturellement tombe ce
que j'attendais l'invitation et ya les
coups de téléphone à l'ambassade de
l'australie le visuel agriculture vendus
et les élans il fait volontiers escale à
canberra
l'accueil et se passe alors en australie
ce parce qu'à boîtier bien parce que mon
grand rêve qui était de trouver un allié
pour la négociation commence craque sur
le groupe de cairns et je n'ai pas pu
faire changer d'avis les landes en
australie tu as quelque chose il paraît
tout ce que je vais entreprendre dans la
suite dans le pacifique va réussir sauf
ça mais ça commence par des amitiés
je suis reçue par un premier ministre de
travaillistes rome et roncq qui me fait
un accueil gigantesque les souvenirs les
volumes sont au bord du rhin l'honneur
de tout nourriture etc
nous faisons connaissance nous nous
plaisons c'est un vrai social-démocrate
ce tacle cette social-démocratie n'ayez
pas peur
ce décathlon ya pas de puissance le
siège est gros comme le tiers de cette
pièce il ya trois salariés c'est rien
l'international social démocrate mais
cela club de mon copain et c'est une
manière de forcer
nous voilà à vie en gros c'est avec le
désespoir qu'il dit je veux pas de
suivre
d'où ce membre du groupe de cairns on
peut pas encore faire ce coup là vous
américain d'où la pagaille dans les
commerces les négociations gricole
mondial mais j'ai un ami et puis il se
passe en france diverses événement dont
inquiet que le gouvernement le président
de la république introduit la
proportionnelle absolue dans nos
élections
ça me parait a créé une console histoire
de france et contre reste des chances de
stabilité de ce pays je démissionne du
gouvernement
ce qui fait que je n'en suis plus ouvrir
de la tragique affaire du rainbow
warrior
ce qui au moins dix aussi ma signature
de toutes les sensibilités de ce côté là
et puis nouvelle calédonie ça se passe
très valeurs nouvelles qu'elles aient
les i conformément au pronostic de
ministre du plan
ça c'est pas si mal que de passage à
paris le miz des affaires étrangères
euros qui s'appelait imz passe à paris
vient me rend la vie tu y es de venir me
voir dans mon petit bureau de député de
l'opposition
une micro qu'est ce que vous ferez en
nouvelle calédonie vous panique de you
n'est plus au pouvoir il ya aucune
espèce de chance raisonnable que le
président mitterrand regagne l'ex en
nous sommes dans le désastre les
affaires financières les échecs c'est un
répit faut aller les voir mais quand
même enfin c'est terrifiant ce qui se
passe je vous êtes en train de peut pas
une guerre civile
l'australie a peur la nouvelle zélande
aussi elle est encore plus proche
alors là faut bien tenir la route 20
volts et et jeudi l'évidence vous
l'auriez tous lit d'ailleurs voyez la
situation j'y connais tu as mais j'avais
eu le drap de la nouvelle qu'a des
lycées que personne ne veut se parler ni
les deux communautés entre elles
la cadac avec la call of duke un
éventuel gouvernement social-démocrate
puisque pour lesquels offs et des
traîtres ils sont prêt à tout lâcher
tout petit sans regarder et pour les
cadets et pour les calacs si simplement
les complices d'une france dont les
gouvernements menthe mensonge public à
plusieurs reprises dans la tragique
histoire de lundi kali est donc je
réponds un bon copain galette qui valent
ressentira au maroc on pourra rien faire
si j'avais des soucis de bois on ne peut
pas se parler faut inventer le
structures ou des gens dotés d'une
grande autorité morale accepteraient
d'aller passer à peu de temps là bas
pour voir sous quelles conditions on
pourrait recommencer à se parler il ne
faudra pas qu'à puis tellement de
projets divers la vente ça depuis un
petit bout sans aucune espèce d'autorité
sur
et puis quand je racontais tout le
détail de tout ça ou plus chrétien de
mes ministres roger fourreaux et comment
la conduit la faire à la paix final on
s'est fait rouer ce mot le saint-esprit
dans cette affaire a frappé très fort je
voulais sa sensibilité je reste laïque
tout entier qui continue à taper fort un
mitterrand est réélu et de hasard encore
bien plus est prévisible il me prend
comme produit alors que la qualité de
relation était telle que c'était je
l'avais traité d'assassin après la
guerre d'algérie c'était non probable
les oreilles dit si bien que j'étais
fort dans les sondages et que ça me
semblait s'imposer en termes
journalistiques mais moi le connaissons
rien c'est arrivé il ferait ça c'était
une super riches a fait valoir qu'une
première entretien avec le président
dans la demi-heure qui suit va dans le
premier entretien qui suit ma nomination
duel qu'elle ait dit monsieur le
président vous avez été conduit à donner
sur fausses informations
cet ordre de traiter militairement le
problème de la grotte d'ouvéa est ce que
il en résulte que la nouvelle que ledit
est un dossier présidentielle que vous
traitez vous suivez tous les jours ou
est ce que c'est un dossier
gouvernemental normal pour c'est un
dossier gouvernemental normal vous vous
en occuper je lis que renie rien vous
verser 6 jours avant il ya encore du
sang partout 20 morts 21 morts dont deux
français j'ai un gouvernement à refaire
à faire une campagne électorale à
croisilles on nous dit souvent ensemble
et je passe trois jours à lire
exclusivement sur le cumul cali de
l'histoire c'est là que j'apprends que
les deux peuples caledonian franco jeux
originaux en pl autres ont été victimes
de mensonge historique celui de 1963
vous la réponse faite à la lettre e ri
par les élus néo calédonien au général
de gaulle en 1958 la loi defferre qui
prévoit l'autonomie des territoires qui
s'applique annuel cueilli va-t-elle
continuer à être appliquée c'est pas de
govou qui répond
ce sont trois ministres d'état antoine
pinay guy mollet et roger frey on le
ferait pour le oui le poids
naturellement la loi defferre continuera
à s'appliquer la double écueil du riz
gardera son assemblée élu un
gouvernement choisit à l'intérieur de
l'assemblée
naturellement le préfet reste chef de ce
gouvernement mais s'il est l'exécutant
d'un collège légal traque depuis 1963
sans préavis sans explication sans rien
un soin en séance de nuit après le
budget oui d'accord je suis trop longs
passe vers 00h30 à projet de loi
d'abrogation de la loi defferre en
cadets d'audi qui supprime l'assemblée
lui supprime le gouvernement local est
attribué tous les pouvoirs aux
commissaires
cette trahison et à la nouvelle qu'elle
y sera et était en algérie la répression
de sétif ses coûts dont on est content d
avoir réussi à la force quand on les a
faits qui créent des colères tel qu'en
20 ans vous avez la guerre toutes les
guerres ont des origines lointaines
je comprends ça j'apprends comprends ça
le deuxième est l'erreur de monsieur
pons qui voulait faire ratifier par un
fer 9 locale un statut inégalitaire en
nouvelle calédonie pendant le
gouvernement chirac de la période de
transition
mais ils étaient embêtés personnes
d'aller voter seuls les blancs de nouvea
les blondes bouge sur tellement pas par
peur et les kanaks par décision du
boycott mais on est tous cousins nous
éduquer les enfants de jean marie
tjibaou paradisum clandestine du claude
estivités on est hébergée par la famille
d'eddy qui est que oui si sa levée
lequel il nie ça vole haut jaillit
d'ailleurs qu'est ce qu'on va faire
et pour se dit j'ai passé par ce pour
quoi vous vous des pauvres venez voter
voter non on boit on verra vous n'avez
jamais voté dans l'histoire de france
mais toujours abstenu on vous connaît
pas on ne vous mesure pas venez donc
voté non c'est votre droit
réponse des autorités des au canada
après tout pourquoi pas c'est vrai que
on a besoin d'une mesure et on n'a pas
peur de puissance on pouvait l'avoir
forte bien attention les gars on est
petit palais
b pas de blague
choisissez date où se réfère dub local
est unique et où la presse locale
française et mondiale ne regardera que
ça et où le commentaire sera notre
mesure
on se promet par écrit chirac change la
vie de pors déplace le référendum
calédonien le premier jour de l'ex et
présidentielle la colère kanak est
terrifiante
une indignité une rente une gifle d'où
la grotte d'ouvéa
c'est ça cinq jours avant la mort
j'arrive j'y connais rien je me souviens
de ce que j'ai inventé pour garer
stevens et je constitue cette mission je
commence par les protestants le
président j'appelle le fait d'être
président de la fédération je suis
protestant une chance une espèce en voie
d espèces à protéger espèces en la
disparation regard des critères de l'onu
voulait 2% et les mariages mixtes nous
tue c'est vrai bravo ou enfin ce sort ma
vision était absolu et au téléphone
monsieur stewart président de la
fédération pour des histoires de france
me disait-il grandes idées suis en
mission si vous permettez monsieur le
premier je la prendrai en charge moi
même au début il me fallait un franc
maçon au nom du seul endroit de nouvelle
calédonie ou caldoches et kanaks et
caldoches et kanaks se rencontrer ap
héros générait accepte tout de suite
ravi après il m'a fallu une glisse
catholique apostolique et romaine
je veux vous dire j'ai commencé par son
président du gardien de courtrai et
l'archevêque de lyon
un prophète au téléphone unique mais si
tu y es magnifique mais il faut
on tombe d'accord selon du chanoine
guiberteau avec qui j'avais négocié dans
l'enseignement agricole privé
j'appelle le challenge guiberteau mais
enfin monsieur le famille j'ai un
employeur avant qui sait l'employeur si
le cardinal de pareil à un grand
politique ça c'est autre chose
le cardinal de paris va dit est ce que
vous savez que l'église catholique
apostolique et romaine a cessé de rendre
des services de puissance publique à
l'êta en france depuis la jeunesse de
louis xiv
vous nous demandez un service je suis
pas très favorable
nous vous livrons un fois depuis trois
ans et puis en plus vous connaissez mal
l'église catholique on peut vous
pardonner mais enfin celle où il va de
soi que le médiateur ne lui disent
catholiques ne peut être que
l'archevêque de nouméa que l'évêque de
nouvea je répondis au cardinal lustiger
que ce que laissait bien par ailleurs un
homme plein d'humour drôle on se
connaissait
je lui réponds sur le cardinal c'est pas
sérieux
vous ne pouvez tout de même pas me dire
à moi qu aux yeux de l'église
cet évêque qui a oublié de parler des
kanaks de vue qu'il est évêque qui sort
lettre l'évêque d'une seule communauté
ne peut pas et l'argument une telle
force que le style j'en conviens la
mission ce fait françois mitterrand dans
sa sagesse accueilli des émeus fait
savoir que c'est très joli bravo d'idées
mais il manque quelque chose
il faudrait dans la mission un
représentant de la tradition du droit
non pas que l'état dépensé 2 l'obtient
du droit en france
c'est génial cette idée a une force
extrême mais c'est tout lui parce que
pour le trouver celui-là le jeudi de
l'ascension en pleines vacances ils
pouvaient retard et ma vision de quinze
jours c'était de faire tout raté tout
mitterrand est temps de cesser de
sagesse nous tes débuts ce qu'on le
président richard jacques perrier à lui
envoyait le gendarme il a cru que
c'était pour excès de vitesse dans un
restaurant du poitou où il fêtait le 20e
anniversaire de mariage de son fils il
veut dit oui par téléphone voilà la
mission six semaines 6 en audience tout
la calédonie vous dira que même les plus
petites communautés quelques valu à
tient beaucoup de polynésiens n'avait
jamais été écoutés je demande à ce
colloque qu'on demande aux archives
nationales de ressortir le rapport il
fait c'est en page c'est un monument
d'histoire qui devrait siéger revo archi
madame le directeur
il faut faire ça la vie 7 est accompagné
de deux préfets le préfet christian
blanc le nom est connu que tétanisé
socialiste j'ai voulu incorporer un
sous-préfet en choisissant l'ancien
conseiller pour l'autre vers de raymond
barre la france l'a 2 joue pas des jeux
partisans le besoin que l'accord soit
complet vendre à gauche était totale
rêvons barbe dit oui dans les dix
minutes il ya beaucoup de noblesse tout
du long de cette histoire dans les 10
minutes et pierre steinmetz qui s'est
retrouvé au conseil constitutionnel a
accepté étaient magnifiques clichés rien
voilà comment ça commence conclure je
peux pas bref nous réussissions ce coup
là
ce n'est pas tout le rainbow warrior est
toujours pas finie nous ne veut toujours
pas d'ambassadeur
c'est moi aussi qui fait conclure la
fièvre du rainbow warrior
comment j'appelle le commandant ma femme
mon bureau j'avais négocié avec le
général commandant l'école de guerre où
il avait été reçu collures tarde pas
d'un an pour deux mois de retard à
l'entrée dans la promotion bien sûr on
fera par spéciale le commandât mafart du
maure bretelles remontées par son
état-major finalement ne refuse et
j'appelle à couper un mois que
j'appelais david languis premier
ministre de nouvelle zélande époque
si vous voulez savoir qui est david lang
il vous imaginez michel charasse vous
mettez 10 cm de moins 15 kg et
licencient ville de plus son large et
beaucoup plus d'énergie et de violences
verbales et de vulgarité dans l'art
d'insulter les autres par le vent une
route mais un homme un vrai et un social
démocrate et je lui dis je ne peux pas
vous rendre ma part il y a dans le litre
ans traité que tu as signé avec jacques
chirac
un article 23 qui dit au cas de non
exécution des traités aux difficultés
par l'une des parties l'autre pourra
faire appel à un tribunal international
cette histoire de ses enfants afin que
je la raconte
c'est pour ça que je pourrai peu de
temps et vous devez le savoir
réponse de david holmes guy ou plutôt je
lui dit il faut que tu attaques la
france devant le tribunal
il faut que l'on sorte qu'on soit jugé
et connaissances des hauts-bassins je
vais repasser travail toi sur les
affaires agricoles
ça reste ce truc l'uruguay n'est pas
fini long silence aggravée par le temps
satellitaire une heure et demie une
minute et demi de silence et le brutal
l'explosif david languis me lâche michel
repens toi tu es complètement fou je
gouverne un petit pays de 3 millions
d'habitants
celle qui personne d'autre ne va jamais
qu'aucun habitant du monde 2 s'est
placée ou sur la carce ce plaisir est
éprouvée nous sommes pas grand chose et
tu aimes demande à voir vous allez
porter plainte contre un pays de 70
millions d'habitants
bon on repérera rincon sécurité doter de
l'arme nucléaire à l'immense histoire
reprends toi michel 6 c'est pas possible
je veux pas faire ça alors david on
attend un siècle avant d'échanger
ambassadeur avant de recommencer à
travailler quand ça se termine tout ça
je veux plus est à la base des
australiens tellement ils ont fidèle et
solidaire tout le long il l'a fait je
vous dois l'aveu que le tribut
l'international a été d'une terrible
indulgence idée de la france nous avons
été condamné que moralement il lui
tribunal passade sa page a expliqué
pourquoi tous les précisions
d'internationaux rendre caduque l'idée
que le coup le soi disant coupable il
n'est pas coupable va faire c'est pas
lui en fait il était le cours d'année
prochaine pour finir s'appelle
simplement manuscrite mans le président
du mr ajoute à la main en plus tout seul
sans ses assesseurs mais il serait bon
que la france finance un petit fond de
réconciliation et d'amitié entre les
dieux peuple pour financer des juges
changeant scolaires des bourses de
recherche des programmes de recherche
conjoints
mesdames et messieurs j'ai extrait du
trésor français 300 mille dollars en
quinze jours il n'y a pas beaucoup de
précédent pour saluer c'est très bien
mais il nous fallait en plus devez le
coprésident français du fonds c'est à ce
moment là que nous avons eue le délivrer
jacques yves cousteau deuxième épisode
qui a accepté d oser landais la hutte de
triomphe j retour nous sommes
réconciliés
merci valable voilà comment tout
commence ça continue avec l'antarctique
et depuis nous collaborons alors depuis
nous avons plus cesser les erreurs les
explosions nucléaires de largement à mon
initiative au début auprès de mitterrand
en plus vous aurez de la purée les
contentieux la découverte c'est que
c'est une richesse immense c'est que
maintenant nous y sommes a accepté grâce
à tout ça et je voudrais pour finir dire
très vite premièrement que la france a
une vocation là qui est de l'ordre de
l'universel nouvelle kennedy et même un
peu polynésie où c'est moins signifiant
nous exerçons à la décolonisation sans
transfert de souveraineté
il y a encore dans le monde et
territoires où ça veut dire quelque
chose
deuxièmement les tout-petits va diatou
fidji sa voix etc
la france est le plus gros donneur de
crédits dettes publiques à tous et tout
petit pays oubliés du monde il y a une
vocation à l'exemplarité pour les grands
états ça fait partie de la vocation
française troisièmement tout ça fait des
millions de kilomètres carrés de zones
économiques et slim arrêté pêche avec
une double responsabilité péché
correctement bien savoir pousser les
négociations seraient espèces à protéger
et est donnée être exemplaire chez nous
deuxième responsabilité la marine
nationale et c'est pour ça que la
défense nationale en calédonie restera
confère à la france par contrat parce
que la marine néo calédonienne n'a pas
les moyens de faire ça participe
à la police internationale de la pêche
dans les eaux du pacifique sud
et c'est une très grande mission dont
j'espère bien je m'occupe d'arctic par
ailleurs qu'elle va s'élargir dans son
chant et danse et contenu donné par la
loi et puis les adultes polymétallique
est donc une vision du monde
mais la france dans le pacifique c'est
l'opérationnalité diplomatie ou ne parle
plus des intérêts si on n'en a plus par
laure francs la france n'a plus
d'intérêt sérieuses duel kennedy nous en
foutons de skull part du marché dit
qu'elle souhaite au genou produit une
soudain drapeau français à l'origine
sent la patte conséquences commerciales
mais nous menons une diplomatie
l'exemplarité de la réconciliation de la
naissance de la fraternité entre dix
hommes des peuples qui se sont trop
longtemps rang lui et maintenant suite
tout ce que j'ai pris trop longtemps
pour vous raconter
nous y sommes bien reçus et bien
accueilli je veux saluer la fraternité
qui nous lie la joie de nos rencontres
et la constance de mes excès les
rapports dont celui avec les landes mais
petit plus constitutivement en plus avec
l'australie puisque la france et
l'australie sont les donations pilote
est majeur de toutes les diplomaties de
l'antarctique
voilà j'ai été trop long je l'entends je
vous avais prévenu quand même comment
voulez vous
merci beaucoup monsieur évidemment
c'était mission impossible je savais
très bien qu'on demande en cinq minutes
c'était c'était impossible alors
simplement oui voilà exactement ce que
jal est proposé en fait je je propose à
nos intervenants de ne pas faire 2 2 2
deux sessions séparer voilà mais nous
allons en faire une seule et développer
le débat à la fin donc je vais
maintenant présenter rapidement les
prochains intervenants madame elisabeth
lorrain qui est directrice d'asie
océanie au ministère des affaires
étrangères puis nous écouterons
l'ambassadrice de nouvelle zélande
également la représentante permanente
auprès de l'osce et de madame rosemary
banks et l'ambassadeur d'australie
monsieur rick wells puis nous écouterons
immédiatement dans la lancée
michel aymeric secrétaire général de la
mer quel beau titre et le vice amiral
jean louis vichot anciennes autorités de
coordination pour les questions
internationales à l'état major de la
marine
merci beaucoup et un à vos micros merci
beaucoup madame monsieur le premier
ministre
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
madame l'ambassadeur messieurs les
ambassadeurs mesdames et messieurs j'ai
quasiment mission impossible de parler
après le premier ministre une telle
expérience une telle vision historique
une telle perspicacité et qui aussi à
développer ce que nous pourrions faire
tous ensemble pour le 21e siècle dans
cette région je voudrais juste éloigner
un témoignage tout récent qui associe
l'ambassadeur de nouvelle-zélande
puisque elle nous avait réunis autour de
du ministre de la culture néo zélandais
qui est aussi ministre en charge des
commémorations pour la première guerre
mondiale et je voulais par ce symbole
évoqué ce que l'on a souvent dit cette
tyrannie de la distance entre la france
métropolitaine
et puis cette région du monde
si fiq je crois que les hommes la
volonté la volonté politique
le courage aussi humain est fait
référence aussi à tous ces soldats
néo-zélandais
ces soldats australiens qui sont venus
sur notre métropole sur la terre de
france
aussi pour nous aider dans les temps
difficiles et bien cette tyrannie de la
distance nous avons su par la volonté
par politique par des idéaux partagés
par des valeurs communes nous avons su
nous avons su l'abolir cette tyrannie de
la distance pardonnez moi cette note un
peu personnel mais je pense qu'il
fallait y rendre hommage et il vous
rendre en bâche madame et monsieur aussi
il y à travers vous voudrez pays
peut-être de manière peut-être plus
rapide plus synthétique pour aider
peut-être à ouvrir ya lancé le débat
notamment avec mes collègues
ambassadeurs qu'est ce que le pacifique
aussi pour pour ce 21ème siècle alors le
pacifique ont à rappeler l'immensité
géographique 1 c'est plus de dix sept
mille cinq cents kilomètres de large
c'est aussi au point de vue économique
et vous le savez tous pour ce nouveau
siècle c'est le moteur de la croissance
mondiale on dit que cela représente à
peu près un tiers du pib mondial et cela
devrait concentrer sur les cinq
prochaines années à venir
près de la moitié de cette croissance
mondiale c'est aussi certains dans deux
des orateurs précédents lots rappelés
c'est le premier espace de ce transit au
monde en flux de marchandises 70% du
trafic mondial vous que prévu que dans
ce contexte si l'importance de la
liberté de navigation et de circulation
qui évoqueront certains orateurs suivant
lors des prochaines tables rondes
c'est aussi plus de 3 milliards
d'habitants c'est à dire 60 % de la
population mondiale
c'est aussi 50 2% de la surface de la
terre 6 des plus grande armée du monde
et la présence de cinq membres du
conseil de sécurité la france et le
royaume uni au titre notamment de leurs
territoires du pacifique
ceci cette importance ce poids dans
l'économie mondiale ce poids aussi il
cette responsabilité en matière de paix
de stabilité à la fois dans
l'environnement régional mais au niveau
mondial c est à ces états du pacifique
on partage cette responsabilité ont des
devoirs et notamment des devoir d'agir
quand je parle de ces états du pacifique
je parle bien entendu de la france la
france a aussi et partage ses devoirs et
ses responsabilités la france état du
pacifique après ce que je viens de nous
dire le premier ministre je crois que il
tout le travail accompli
il n'y a plus aucun doute dans la
perception que l'on peut avoir sur ce
sujet la france c'est aussi cinq cent
cinquante mille français installés dans
deux trois collectivités territoriales
c'est aussi une zone économique une zone
économique de plus qui représente les
deux tiers de la zone économique
française c'est les forces armées de
nouvelle calédonie de polynésie
française et un réseau diplomatique vous
l'avez évoqué déjà de cinq ambassades
dans la région
la france devienne un état du pacifique
une population un territoire une
autorité reconnue pour tous et là des
partenaires majeurs et je veux citer la
nouvelle-zélande et l'australie
l'australie vous le savez attire
beaucoup les français parce que nous
avons plus de 60000 français et nous en
avons six mille en nouvelle zélande
c'est donc aussi cet intérêt de la
population française qui grandit vers le
pacifique sud avec l'australie nous
avons un partenariat stratégique
nous sommes membres du g20 nous avons
des responsabilités essentielles comme
avec la nouvelle zélande en matière
économique en matière de facilitation du
commerce et nous avons aussi deux
partenaires extrêmement actif en matière
de libre échange de zone de libre
échange peut être ils pourront nous en
parler un peu plus longuement sur tous
ces partenariat transpacifique qui vont
se créer et l'impact que cela rap avoir
pour nos échanges et le développement
nos échanges
je voudrais aussi rappeler comme l'ont
fait d'autres orateurs l'importance pour
nos collectivités territoriales de
l'insertion dans sept ans contexte
régional et du rôle qu'elle peut jouer
en matière économique on a évoqué les
ressources minières la nouvelle
calédonie qui a des accords très proches
en matière de nico elle avec le japon et
la corée du sud en matière de ressources
halieutiques en matière de tourisme
il y a des potentialités énormes elles
sont exploitées on peut aller encore
plus loin et je crois que cette ces
interactions notamment avec les pays
voisins comme la volt et le premier
ministre sont extrêmement importantes
pour tous
parmi les grands acteurs internationaux
mais je pense que mes collègues
d'australie nouvelle zélande reparlera
il y a deux acteurs majeurs aussi dans
la région c'est la chine qui a exprimé
un intérêt renouvelé pour le pacifique
sud
il y a aussi les états unis je pense que
la présence par exemple de la secrétaire
d'état
au dernier vrai dialogue post forum des
îles du pacifique était quand même très
symbolique de ce regard de ces
puissances vers le pacifique sud
les enjeux les potentialités c'était
aussi important pour nous tous et auquel
nous souhaitons contribuer c'est la
stabilité et la sécurité régionale et
qui est marquée par une fragilité
croissante de certains pays moins
avancés du pacifique fragilité parfois
politiques fragilité sans doute
économique par leur statut de pma comme
il est attesté aussi fragilité
climatique fragilité sur lequel il faut
que nous travaillons ensemble nous
l'étions déjà au niveau régional mais
aussi dans les grandes enceintes
internationales qu'il s'agisse des
problèmes climatiques ou des problèmes
que l'on peut trouver en matière de
développement les évolutions politiques
institutionnelles des collectifs
françaises du pacifique monsieur le
premier ministre vous avez évoqué je me
ferais très très modeste à ce sujet je
passerai donc plus tôt il vous l'avait
déjà évoqué aussi pardonnez moi j'ai
l'impression de me répéter un peu
l'effort financier les transferts
budgétaires importants que la france
s'efforce de faire ces collectivités et
qui représente plus de 2,5 milliards
d'euros
j ajouterai l'aide fournie par l' agence
française de développement le fonds
pacifique et tout ce que nous faisons
aussi en matière de coopération
régionale avec notamment l'australie la
nouvelle zélande notamment s'agissant
des exercices militaires conjoints croix
du sud du dispositif france entre la
france l'australie la nouvelle zélande
en matière de gestion post catastrophe
et c'est un dispositif que nous avons
mis en oeuvre notamment lors du passage
du cyclone
evans nous avons aussi une présence et
une volonté d'être très active dans les
organisations de coopération régionale
notamment avec la création de la
communauté du pacifique et dont je
voudrais saluer le secrétaire qui est
présent au premier rang de la salle avec
le choix de nouméa pour installer des 47
le siège de cette communauté du
pacifique vous savez aussi que la france
participe activement au programme
régional pour l'environnement
elle est aussi membre du forum des îles
du pacifique qui a été créée en 1971 par
l'australie à la nouvelle-zélande et je
voudrais particulièrement souligné la
volonté qui a été la nôtre volonté de
voir associer nos nounous collectivités
territoriales la nouvelle calédonie la
polynésie française puis wallis et
futuna à cet acer à ce forum voilà si
vous le permettez je crois que je lance
quelques pistes de réflexion je vais
vous épargner du temps et peut-être je
compléterai si vous le permettez lors de
débats
je vous remercie beaucoup madame lorrain
et nous allons tout de suite écoutez
madame l'ambassadrice de nouvelle
zélande
rosemary banks dans les coteaux tenkoto
114 nomade à l'ima et qui tenait qu'aux
oui tenkoto tenkoto tenkodogo toi
monsieur le premier ministre
merci messieurs les sénateurs mesdames
et messieurs merci de m'avoir invité à
prendre la parole devant un
impressionnant rassemblement d'amis du
pacifique pour vous parler des
perspectives de la nouvelle zélande sur
la présence de la france dans notre
région
maintenant et à l'avenir expérience
personnelle je sais bien que le
pacifique reste toujours attaché à ce
qu'ils ont vécu
l'immensité de lotion l'éclat des
étoiles la richesse et la diversité de
la culture et de langue
le pcsi guey la façon typique de faire
les choses mais si vous connaissez bien
la région
vous ne pouvez qu'être inquiète des
graves défis auxquels nos partenaires du
pacifique doivent faire face on a déjà
évoqué ces défis qui sont d'autres
économiques démographiques
environnementale et aussi qui concerne
la gouvernance et la sécurité au sens
large le changement du climat menace
d'accélérer tous ces défis pour la
nouvelle-zélande
nous plaçons la stabilité dans la région
du pacifique sud comme l'objectif
principal de notre politique étrangère
il s'ensuit que notre assistante
d'assistance au développement est
focalisé sur cette région
cependant nous pouvons espérer faire une
différence dans une région tellement
vaste que si nous travaillons en très
étroite collaboration avec d'autres
l'australie est naturellement notre
partenaire immédiate
dans tout ce que nous entreprenons dans
le pacifique nous nous tournons vers la
france en tant qu ami loyal et précieux
pour notre région
nous apprécions vivement son engagement
dans le pacifique
nous sommes particulièrement
reconnaissants de à la france de son
soutien fidèle
quant aux efforts du forum des îles du
pacifique à encourager un retour à la
démocratie aux fidji nous souhaitons que
cet engagement de se poursuivre
je vais commenter brièvement trois
dimensions de la présence française dans
la région
l'engagement des réseaus sa présence en
tant que pouvoir venant de la métropole
et l'image de la france à travers sa
diplomatie régionale
la nouvelle zélande attache beaucoup
d'importance à la présence militaire de
la france dans le pacifique et aux
accords que nous avons en place avec
l'australie et la france pour la
coopération en responsable des strophes
naturel à la recherche et au sauvetage
et à la surveillance maritime afin de
s'y essayer de contrôler la pêche
illégale dans cette vaste région
nous nous attendons donc à l'avenir à
des pressions exercées sur ses réseaux
ce et aussi en raison de la présence des
pêcheurs turier de pays qui ne
respectent pas les règles par conséquent
nous souhaitons que la france maintienne
et si possible intensifie l'engagement
qu'elle a déjà comme dans la
surveillance maritime en tant que
puissance de la métropole
la nouvelle-zélande est prête à
travailler avec la france alors que
celle ci continue à définir sa relations
futures avec la nouvelle calédonie et la
polynésie française
ne souhaitant que la nouvelle calédonie
notre plus proche voisin reste stable et
vienne avec le temps plus étroitement
intégrée dans la région notre ministre
des affaires étrangères mari me caler 6
1 13 personnellement il a souligné la
nécessité d'un dialogue actif du
gouvernement calédoniennes en direction
de ses voisins du pacifique pour
renforcer ses liens avec la région et
développer sa propre identité dans le
pacifique et sa présence au sein des
membres du forum
alors qu'une période cruciale approche
dans le processus d' accords de nouméa
la nouvelle-zélande se tiennent prêtes à
partager toute expérience pertinente
nous voulons être constructifs dans
notre travail avec la france au cours
des deux prochaines années pour aider la
transition de la nouvelle calédonie vers
quels que soient les futures relations
que seront démocratiquement décider seul
arrête après tu la façon de faire les
choses dans le pacifique être prêt à
s'entraîner ma dernier comme des cancers
l'image et la présence de la france que
la france peut tapoter à la région
pacifique
aucun pays ainsi les indépendants ne
peut établir une ambassade à paris
donc c'était une bénéficie pas comme le
de contact journalier avec le
gouvernement français
et avec l'administration en france
nous voyons un pays qui est engagé à
être impartial pour ces territoires du
pacifique est ouvert à toute perspective
équitablement négocier pour leur avenir
ces petits pays insulaires voir en la
france une puissance distante
la france a néanmoins grâce à son
approche moderne et constitue un message
positif à faire passer
ce message mérite d'être mieux compris
dans tout le pacifique
vous êtes la france vous êtes un membre
du conseil de sécurité un pays qui
accepte aisément ses responsabilités
mondiales et une puissance européenne
qui a statut et influence les états
insulaires du pacifique où la france
n'est pas représenté voudront vous êtes
entendre dans le pacifique web comme
vous le savez bien
cette façon particulière de fait les
affaires dans la région est basée sur le
respect mutuel par l'intermédiaire de
contacts réguliers et des relations
chaleureuses ce qui peinait de pas venir
doucement et pas de réels échanges
un vrai consensus nous encourageons la
france a lancé
autant d'initiatives d'ouverture que
possible dans le pacifique à partir de
ses représentations dans la région et à
partir de paris pour conclure quoi que
réserve l'avenir à la relation entre la
france et ses territoires du pacifique
nous souhaitons qu'elle reste notre
partenaire dans la région
l'assistance fiable d'une amie véritable
comme la france sera toujours vivement
apprécié mexique
australie merci mesdames
monsieur le premier ministre à mesdames
et monsieur a premièrement à je voudrais
vous remercier pour l'invitation de
d'aborder ce sujet ici en votre présence
deuxièmement et personnellement
permettez moi de dire comme je me
réjouis de d'entendre autant de voix ici
qu'ils réclament pour la france
une présence majeure dont le pacifique
pour l'australie le pacifique est une
région d'importance capitale
l'australie est le partenaire le plus
important des états insulaires du
pacifique en matière sécuritaire
économique et dead le monde se tourne
vers l'australie pour qu'elle joue un
rôle de premier plan dans le pacifique
et juge l'australie sur les performances
car enregistrée dans cette région les
états insulaires du pacifique sont
confrontés à des défis de taille un
tiers de leur population vit dans la
pauvreté
nombre d'entre eux voient leurs
perspectives économiques limités par
leur isolation
ils sont exposés à des catastrophes
naturelles parfois extrêmes la stabilité
de certains de ses états a été parfois
menacés par des différences est ni les
états insulaires du pacifique recouvre
une vaste zone du globe assurer la
promotion de leur prospérité de leur
stabilité et de leur santé
environnementale revêt une importance
considérable pour le communauté
internationale
pour atteindre ces objectifs la
coopération internationale était
essentielle pour l'australie la france
constitue une présence importante et
positive dans le pacifique et il s'agit
donc d'un à d'un partenaire stratégique
majeur
le soutien apporté par la france à ses
trois collectivités du pacifique
représente une contribution de premier
ordre à la stabilité et au développement
de la région dans son ensemble et la
présence militaire française est un
atout pour le pacifique
la nouvelle calédonie est l'un des plus
proches voisins de de l'os très lié par
son truchement la france et l'australie
partage a une frontière commune dont le
maire de corail l'australie a apporté et
continuera d'apporter un soutien fort au
processus de l'accord de nouméa qui est
amené la stabilité en nouvelle calédonie
l'australie souhaite vivement que
l'accord de nouméa continuent d'être
mises en oeuvre de manière fructueuse
l'australie va continuer à travailler
avec la france pour promouvoir une
intégration plus étroite de la nouvelle
calédonie à la région y compris en
soutenant son adhésion en qualité de
membre à part entière au forum des îles
du pacifique et l'australien courage
également une libéralisation en plus
accrue de l'économie néo calédonienne
qui contribuent aura à son intégration
économique régionale
la france aux côtés de l'australie et de
la nouvelle-zélande contribue grandement
aux opérations d'urgence menées suite
aux catastrophes naturelles dont le
pacifique
grâce à l'accord france en décembre de
l'année dernière ce partenariat
révélée d'une valeur inestimable dans
l'intervention qui qui a fait suite au
cyclone tropical qui a dévasté samoa à
wallis et futuna et certaines zones de
fidji les activités de surveillance
maritime menée conjointement
conjointement par l'australie et la
france est à préserver des ressources
halieutiques menacé et dans le cadre du
groupe de coordination quoi trilatérale
de défense des responsables australiens
français néo-zélandais et étasuniennes
unienne se rencontrent régulièrement
pour partager des informations et
coordonner leurs activités de
surveillance maritime
l'australie accorde également une grande
importance au rôle que joue le france un
en concentrant l'attention de l'union
européen sur la région l'australie
coopère étroitement avec le programme
d'envergure de l'union européenne en
matière d'aidé au développement dont la
région pacifique et formule le voeu que
la france continuera de se faire le
chantre des problèmes éthiques liées au
pacifique à bruxelles
l'australie souhaite étendre sa
coopération avec la france en ce qui a
trait aux questions liées au pacifique
et dans ce contexte des défauts roux est
tel que celui ci contribue
considérablement à la compréhension des
enjeux a qui sont respectivement les
nôtres ainsi que de ceux des nations et
et peuples du pacifique l'australie
souhaiteraient travailler de concert
avec la france pour améliorer l échange
d'informations et de position sur la
pacifique et finalement mesdames et
messieurs la coopération dans le
pacifique constituer un élément
important du partenariat stratégique que
l'australie et la france ont signé il ya
un nom l'australie veut renforcer la
relation bilatérale qui l'unît à la
france dans une large palette de
domaines notamment dans le cadre du
monde à d'australiens à 2013 2014 au
conseil de sécurité des nations unies et
de la présidence du g20 en 2014 je vous
remercie
voilà pour une partie de ce colloque
consacré à la france dans le pacifique
si vous souhaitez le revoir notre site
internet publicsenat.fr a tout de suite
à l'émission politique de la rédaction
de public sénat preuve par 3 qui
accueille ce soir la ministre déléguée à
l'innovation et à l'économie numérique
fleur pellerin en bonne fin de journée à
tous